if you are a summerlin property owner  there's a chance the county owes you  money  some property owners in summerlin  entitled refunds from a  tax district that expired back in  december now that money is from tax  payments  over and above the cost of a project  that actually began 23 years ago  clark county established the project to  landscape and fund improvements in an  area between  charleston up here to the north twain to  the south essentially the 215 beltway  on the west and wallapie most of these  in zip code  eight nine one three five now refunds  because you're wondering about that  amount  they range from 161 bucks to over a  thousand dollars nearly four million  dollars  still to be claimed more than 4500  properties are  due a refund only 1800 property owners  at this time have filed for refunds the  deadline to submit your claim  is may 24th now to find out if you're  due to get a refund simply visit our  website  8newsnow.com